because that's how hard we do I took
everything heat another guy that was
cheap that gave me like a tenth of a
gram to short on coke but he was on this
construction site his [ __ ] aunt
lived on the property she was just a fat
woman that wouldn't answer the door and
I opened up the screen gone right up the
stairs you think is that you whatttt
upstairs I took [ __ ] everything they
took it down the stairs and wait for the
deli the town crier you know everything
I borrowed 20 from them to take the bus
home because Perry would drop dead
person God at least he cocoa he'd rob me
20 go home that's [ __ ] what so Perry
came to my house never forget this I was
laying on the bed I'm coming that off
from the coat I had only felt a little
bit
I had to smash outside Shirley was
coming and I'm laying on the fence he
doesn't like my window I got like and I
went like this and when he got in the
window put the curtain down like [ __ ]
level he went down he was if you want to
fight he want my coat get off my Michael
prove it to me I'll meet you this is my
antenna fire it was insane I know it's
you I know it was you
that was not a good scene fun because
bloody hey bloody beat him up on that
there was blood everywhere ruddy hate
him so he came up there tonight
talks like my dog it's all by buying the
coke was good everybody follow
[Music]
la forza del destino [ __ ] this is
a monster shit-stirrer that means voices
of the steno in german
that's how we droplet today we drop a
Nazi quote even with the door open this
fat [ __ ] cloudy in here what have you
done lately you [ __ ] maggots you
gotta keep one eye looking over your
shoulder cuz it's gonna get hot ha ha
that's right and in the end you'll crack
up slide down south
hide your [ __ ] head in the sand you
know why just another sad old man all
alone dying of cancer that's it good on
exit listening to this that you're gonna
die a cancer oh and your [ __ ] stomach
is churning
this is Pink Floyd we have mushrooms
tonight yes we do
we got the batch of debt coming here
thing that spirits for all the bad
spirits a little smoke forget the party
started this [ __ ] and painting on a
little boy
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me you want
Monday you got [ __ ] Monday
[Music]
oh [ __ ] somebody's gonna see the devil
tonight
it's a beautiful day to be alive
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
here we go listen the dog stop it
if you've ever done ask them listen for
this these dogs are talking to you
they're telling you it's gonna be
alright brother
it's just some acid don't worry about
nothing it's just your mind playing
tricks on you this is what makes you
tough because if this goes through your
mental and you're on a hit acid forget
that DMT and mushrooms and all that
[ __ ] stuff I'm coming to you direct
with the real [ __ ] deal this place
[Music]
you could do acid and wood stain this
then come see me that diem [ __ ]
suck my dick that's kid stuff get that
with the propeller
[Music]
are you kidding me please like guitar
that's pain the pain comes out of your
heart when you hear this [ __ ] I hear are
you [ __ ] nuts
we're going deep today it's Monday I
don't give a [ __ ] what the day this
dates don't matter as long as you're
swinging stick are you like me now here
we go here we go everyone so light up
with the anthem back on to remind you
[ __ ] of why your hearts even
take it right here right here
Vincent Gilmore talking talking to you
[Music]
are you [ __ ] nuts mother bondage
[Music]
everything else is background music
scary movies
your grandmother's [ __ ] [ __ ] got you
right here
and then he drops London at the end we
acid trip and when you lose control here
we go you reap the harvest you have sown
you understand me so now go [ __ ]
yourself you wanna hang out with these
[ __ ] ease that now they don't have your
back you see say and when the fear grows
that's right it grows [ __ ] like
a weed in your head
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is knowledge [ __ ] right here
his lawyer you need some words and
backwards and you'll be fine they can't
[ __ ] with you out there Lake to lose the
weight you used to me - oh man oh [ __ ]
Oh
[Music]
there we go now you're going to the
foxhole dragged down by oh [ __ ]
then they just leave and they leave this
on stage and you're sitting there
[ __ ] where's the band why do I hear
this guy come on oh-oh-oh-oh if you
don't eat edibles and you don't hear
that oh oh oh you're not going deep
enough you understand me that's how we
do it here in the Churchill what's
happening now [ __ ] do not
forget Charlotte I'm coming in heavy I
got two mules coming in with stars and
machinima juice in case the one gets
taken down the other mule makes it you
follow me I got all chapels people
[ __ ] making the delivery we're going
deep and Charlotte tonight tonight
Thursday night when I [ __ ] around you
want to [ __ ] around go to some other
[ __ ] tip-top show maybe there's a
ping-pong tournament in town or
something his the uncle joey's show
Thursday 8 o'clock Charlotte keep
[ __ ] around
hold on I'll put the part on to take you
deep then we start the podcast
[Music]
becomes badass a whole side that's 30
minutes you just said that with your
mouth open you just sit there with your
mouth open you understand me you have no
[ __ ] idea
[Music]
look here's point supplies
we got a [ __ ] remedy [ __ ] shattered
joint still the cases an earthquake
we're right here
case there's an earthquake we're right
here we go here we go here we go who was
bought in a house
[Music]
full of pain oh [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
knocking spits and the fan who was told
what to do by the man that's why we
don't lose [ __ ]
at the end the acid sit down during this
year beaten and you're just like he's
talking about me but he heats on you
tears you up dude he destroys your
insides
oh [ __ ] who was wasting away here we go
here we go who was only a stranger at
home
and you're like what I gotta start
hanging out the house are you [ __ ]
nuts that's why people of us it's what
you know why it's the truth
[ __ ]
[Music]
here we go
[Laughter]
Larry from perennial does the trick who
was dragged down by a star youtube.com /
c / Joey beers that's the place to be
that's your album for the day that
should be the first time in your [ __ ]
thing
animals Pink Floyd everything else is
background music you show up with the
dave Andrews [ __ ] band and I'm
stamping in that [ __ ] eyeball and
donate the other retina the [ __ ] some
blind dude with one eye I love you
caucus up to stay black
Charlotte Thursday Charlotte Friday and
Charlotte Saturday you have C night the
tickets already sold down so you better
show up Friday Thursday [ __ ] I
love you
stay black youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
that's the place to be [ __ ]